[Musica]
1500 in quella parte dell'europa del
nord che corrisponde più vena olanda e
belgio
le città erano ricchissime mercanti
banchieri
gioiellieri
proprietari di navi
e tutta questa è la borghesia molto
ricca chiamava nelle sue case nelle sue
corti pittori che dipingessero la
magnificenza delle case la ricchezza dei
vestiti
quasi tutti ma uno
questo
breve non superava di questo si
preoccupava del fatto che c e
concittadini non si accorgesse di quello
che accadeva tra loro che fossero
concentrati egoisticamente
sui loro interessi e unipi già questo
quadro vedete c'è un proprietario
terriero compagni curiali chiara
guardando davanti a sé
poi c'è un pastore che guarda in alto un
pescatore guarda in basso
vascelli che vanno un paesaggio
idilliaco ma siamo attenti in fondo a
destra
c'è una gamba che sporge
icaro sta affogando
un ragazzo che ha cercato di sconfiggere
legge di gravità se incollata alle ali
sulle spalle con della cera è riuscito a
donare ma il sole ha sciolto da c'era il
ragazzo è precipitato sta negando il
primo uomo che è cercato di volare sta
negando nessuno se ne accorge
c'è stata la indifferenza
nessuno si è preso cura e poi
quest'altro acquario questo è la salita
al calvario si chiama sempre di
primavera è difficile scorgere cristo
qui in mezzo guardate in tutti questi
quadri si è ricordata e servite mente
c'è gesù in prima fila non c'è solo il
primo piano e quegli altri qui invece no
qui gesù è disperso in mezzo agli altri
lo si vede appena
e gli altri sono distratti in basso a
destra c'è la madre di gesù con le sue
amiche che piange signori che parlano
dalla caccia bambini che giocano gente
distratta
sta accadendo una cosa straordinaria e
un uomo di poco più di 30 anni che ha
cambiato le sorti dell'occidente la
cultura le idee in modo di agire che ha
detto le beatitudini
beati i poveri di spirito beato chi ha
fame e sete di giustizia
che vuol dire prenderti di cura
di quelli che 9 fame e sete di giustizia
di quelli che sono poveri di spirito
ecco quest'uomo sta andando al patibolo
ma nessuno se ne accorge
vedete lei differenza
l'indifferenza incontrarli prendi sicura
gramsci aveva scritto io odio gli
indifferenti di odio di differenti
e qual è stata la prima di quella è la
prima vittima dell'indifferenza oggi e
l'ambiente
pensate che per la prima volta nella
storia dell'umanità su un milione di
particelle dell'atmosfera
poco meno di 500 sono di anidride
carbonica e continua a crescere
sapete questo che vuol dire che noi
alleviamo i nostri figli ei nostri
nipoti in modo che siano caldi d'inverno
che se possibile facciano un po di
vacanza d'estate che giochino che impari
non sia possibile una lingua che vadano
bene a scuola si consistono in futuro
però in quale mondo
vivranno questi ragazzi se non cambiamo
i nostri comportamenti
avranno più tumori
avranno più malattie della pelle più
malattie degli occhi e quindi se
vogliamo avere cura di loro dobbiamo
avere cura dell'ambiente che è una
grande vittima dell'indifferenza
ma dà maggiore vittima delle differenza
o meglio del non avere cura e la
democrazia
guardate questa immagine vedete nel 2005
i paesi liberi erano 89 nel 2020 sono 82
sono diminuiti i paesi parzialmente
liberi
da 58 sono 159 i paesi non liberi sono
cresciuti di moto dal 45 al 54 oggi il
60 per cento della popolazione mondiale
non vive in condizioni di libertà
vent'anni fa il 60 per cento della
popolazione mondiale e viveva in
condizioni di povertà la democrazia è
regredita guardate queste immagini
la riconoscete si è l'attacco al
congresso americano
c'è un la più grande democrazia
dell'occidente non è stata in grado di
frenare una masnada di facinorosi che ha
invaso
il luogo della rappresentanza dei più
grandi paesi del mondo occidentale
non è stata capace di curare se stessa
di cura era sua la struttura della
democrazia il fondamento della
democrazia una cosa del genere a cadute
d'italia
a roma un gruppo di facinorosi invaso
con la violenza e distrutto la camera
del lavoro di roma come qui a torino nei
primi anni venti
un gruppo di facinorosi assalto alla
camera del lavoro la distrusse bruciò
tutti i documenti
perché non siete si era avuto il tempo o
la voglia di prestare cura i valori
della democrazia e quindi era cresciuta
la non democrazia
vedete è la democrazia
non non vive soltanto di classi
dirigenti ha bisogno di cittadini
democratici
che vuol dire cittadini democratici
cittadini che abbiano cura di sé e degli
altri più o meno cura delle istituzioni
raccontato che vi nel viaggio in america
che la differenza tra gli europei e
americani era questa se ai cittadini di
una strada europea si accorgono che c'è
un buco nella strada
cosa fanno
si uniscono insieme fanno un corteo per
protestare davanti al sindaco
cenni e stati uniti quei cittadini si
riuniscono e si mettono d'accordo su
come coronare la buca sono due modi
diversi di guardare le cose i secondi si
prendono cura e questo già più
importante prendersi cura
e
forse vi ricorderete che due ragazzine
qualche giorno fa hanno aggredito
insultato picchiato un loro compagno
perché ebreo
gli ha detto ti aspettano i forni
una signora che è morta a roma ha
chiesto che il socio barra ci fosse la
bandiera nazista
guardate quando sapete che nel 2021 ogni
tre giorni è stata uccisa da ogni tre
giorni è stata uccisa una donna
ci saranno le penne i processi eccetera
ma guardate non basta bisogna educare ai
valori
perché il processo la pena serve la
giustizia serve al mare ieri non devono
prevenire i mari domani e il male domani
si prevede educando avendo cura avendo
cura degli altri c'è una cosa che è
molto colpito in 60 mila anni fa anzi un
importante archeologo tedesco ha
scoperto nel nord e iraq negli anni
sessanta il corpo
direi vesti di una persona che era
vissuta al 60 mila anni fa gli studi
successivi hanno scoperto una cosa
pensate che quest'uomo era morto crimine
o 40 anni 40 anni montieri di allora era
come 80 ad adesso quindi aver vissuto
lungo era privo di una mano era zoppo
aveva la tempia sfondata e probabilmente
sordo e senza un occhio
ma era vissuto sapete perché che gli
altri della sua tribù avevano avuto cura
di lui
mi ha colpito invece che qualche mese fa
è stata scoperta una signora che era
morta da mesi in casa sua e nessuno se
n'era accorto
perché nessuno
direi e guardate questo a dire cura è
una cosa fondamentale avere quello di
gargano vuol dire avere anche pure ai se
stessi preoccuparsi
elaborati non ci sono solo senti
negativi pensate i medici e gli
infermieri durante il comic quanto hanno
rischiato e quanti sono morti per avere
cura degli altri e siate gli insegnanti
chieda si sono attrezzati a fare la
didattica distanza
guardate io penso che noi consigliamo
figli e nipoti a un ceto professionale
che ritiene da 6 anni a 24 25 a un ceto
professionale al quale non riconosciamo
dignità sociale non abbiamo cura di chi
cura educa i nostri figli non si nipoti
in questa grave questo gene verdura per
ora
non è solo
non è solo un problema di retribuzione
un problema
di attenzione a quello che accade a
quello che succede attorno a noi
e insieme forse voi
ricorderete quello che ho creduto
trent'anni fa
non c'è bisogno di commentare le
conoscete questo immagino
quei due magistrati sono morti
perché avevano avuto cura
della democrazia
quella della giustizia
cura della legalità
e permettetemi di energia i nomi
di una ragazza di alcuni ragazzi
i nomi di falcone
borsellino lo conoscete tutti
vi leggo dagli altri nomi
vito schifani
rocco dicillo antonio
montinaro
agostino catalano walter cosina
emanuela loi
claudio traina vincenzo li muli
morti con loro
[Applauso]
morti con loro e guardate in una
democrazia non ci possono essere morti
in serie a e morti di serie c
non è possibile non è possibile
dimenticarlo
e guardate che
uomini come falcone con borse non
sapevano che se fossero stati uccisi
sarebbero state scuole piazze funerali
di stato onori ricordi memorie
ma quegli altri sapevano
che sarebbe stato inferiore
[Applauso]
e
sapete che cosa sono morti
per una parola che non si pronuncia più
per una parola che si chiama patria
patria
guardate patria non quella delle nazioni
violente e aggressive e militari no la
parte della costituzione
quella che dice che siamo uguali kiem ho
diritto al lavoro alla sicurezza
all'istruzione alla salute e che
dobbiamo lavorare insieme per far
crescere il nostro paese loro hanno
fatto e cerchiamo guardate in questi
trent'anni ci sarà un sacco di cerimonie
credo
un sacco di retorica
stiamo attenti perché mondo per onorare
quelle persone non è celebrare un giorno
e ricordare ogni giorno quello che hanno
fatto per cercare esse impegni di loro
[Applauso]